first of all congratulations on the
award of the Nobel Peace Prize - I can
thank you this is very very surreal hey
in their statement the Norwegian Nobel
Committee described a new momentum
behind efforts to rid the world of
nuclear weapons where do you think that
new energy is coming from I think it
comes from just mobilizing people around
the world I think with 21st century
having using weapons of mass destruction
to kill civilians is no longer
acceptable the Cold War is over a long
time ago we can no longer accept these
weapons and I think that perspective has
really mobilized a new generation of
campaigners and the people who've been
working on this for a very long time
last month the majority of nations voted
to adopt a new treaty prohibiting
nuclear weapons that has still to be
ratified but what do you think the
treaty will achieve when ratified I
think you will achieve a lot of pressure
on States to sign the treaty there's a
lot of governments who have not yet
signed it so it increases the pressure
on them it stigmatizes nuclear weapons
it declares under international law that
these weapons are unacceptable and now
illegal as well so I think it's a very
strong signal to nuclear-armed states
that they have to disarm and it's not
just it's not just a symbolic treaty it
will have concrete impact on policies
and practice thank you know what what do
you think the award of the Nobel Peace
Prize will do for your work at ICANN oh
it will it will mean everything I think
it's it's really you know we're more
organization and we have a lot of
organizations that are members but have
worked with little resources and lack of
media attention to this issue and kind
of ignored by mainstream media so I
think this will really this will mean
the world to us this is going to change
everything and I can is a is a
collective of worldwide partner
organizations isn't it yes we are
sixty-eight organizations Oh in 101
countries that's truly a worldwide
movement yeah
and lastly if individuals want to get
involved in your campaign what can they
do to help I think they can get really
active demand by the demand their
governments to find us freely and to
ratify this treaty make sure to
challenge policies that rely on nuclear
weapons even in countries in countries
that don't have Nuclear Posture a part
of nuclear weapons alliances countries
can sign this treaty and should sign
this treaty and should reject nuclear
weapons so there's a lot of potential to
get involved so if people want to put
pressure what's the best thing they
could do demand their governments to
find the treaty right okay and lastly
you as executive director how do you
feel about this news completely
overwhelm right now I feel like I can
already be extremely happy this has been
a collective work by so many people
around the world for a long time and
it's just really a huge honor once again
many congratulations on the award and
thank you thank you very much indeed for
speaking to us thank you thank you